[Music]
an accident what I'd like to have a
moment of silence in honor of Caroline
found the miracle season tells the true
story of a community stunned with grief
in 2011 high school volleyball captain
Caroline found died in a moped accident
weeks later her mother died of cancer
you go through this unfathomable tragedy
and Hollywood comes knocking what was
your initial reaction when you got
approached to turn your story into a
film well I'd say our initial reaction
was thanks but we're just not quite
ready for this and our hearts hearts are
still a little wrong well it was just
too painful for everybody involved
years later Ernie and Brea's linked up
with a production company they trusted
and got the ball rolling with some major
star power
you're being portrayed by Helen Hunt and
William Hurt these are Oscar winners I
mean this is this is a big deal it was
crazy
yeah you know but it was an honor this
movie gave me the opportunity to look
into my daughter's face who came with me
and the face of these actors and get to
say things to them like do this for
yourself and you did this so often as
women you know we are interrupted
someone else takes the credit for the
idea and as lovely as it is to handle
that with grace it's even more lovely to
step into your power which these women
do in the movie this is our year
newcomers Erin Moriarty and Anika yarosh
told et making the movie was extremely
emotional I remember when I read the
script for the first time I was just
bawling my eyes out yeah I was like
there's no way that this happens like
this has totally been like dramatis eyes
when I met them that's when the tears
came because I was like I just I was
almost in denial when loveliest human
beings taken away so prematurely and go
through that with her mother as well
we're not champions anymore win or lose
I'm so proud that day on set where you
saw Danica in Caroline's Jersey
explained to me what went through your
mind a bit of a shocker for me but
luckily Danica was all smiles and all
hugs and our eyes met and all of a
sudden seemed to be okay but I did
afterwards have to turn away and walk
away a little bit and kind of look up to
look up above and but it was it was
pretty surreal
was it therapeutic for you to do this
film oh I would say yes a little bit
it's a it's it's a long process and
ongoing process
our main goal was to was to share a
message that that young women have the
power and strength and fortitude to to
bring themselves together and if that
message can get across it a little bit
[Applause]
you
[Music]